Lal dead is one of the most
internationally famous figures to come
out of medieval Kashmir she lived her
life as a Wandering aesthetic while
composing her famous poems or Vox that
would be orally transmitted for
centuries after her death by people from
different religious and cultural
affiliations in these poems we find
teachings and expressions of the highest
mystical States as well as some rare
glimpses into her life lalded was
initiated into the spiritual tradition
of Kashmir shaivism it's fascinating
that laldat basically offers us a full
rundown of the spiritual path in this
way the Vox give us a view into her mind
as she travels Inward and eventually as
she reaches the ecstatic recognition of
reality as it is exemplified really well
in this poem quote when the dirt was
wiped away from my mind's mirror people
knew me for a lover of God
when I saw him there so close to me he
was all I was nothing